hello everyone and welcome to round one
of norway chess the only tournament in
the world where there are no draws now
what does this mean well it means that
if the classical game ends in a draw and
armageddon is immediately played and
then uh the
uh the the the round is decided so
the classical game might end in a draw
but one player will win the encounter uh
so you get more points for winning in
classical but it's uh better to you know
even if you get a draw to to win the
armageddon game at least and most games
i believe will finish that way uh
however even in round one some games
ended in a decisive result in classical
so hope you guys will enjoy this one
it's a really it's truly a master class
so you guys can learn a lot from it uh
so let's let's dive straight into it
it's vishwanathan anand versus maxime
vashilagrav again with the black pieces
and you know that maxine always brings
something special to the party when he
when he has the black pieces even even
in classical as you'll see here so anand
opens with e4 which uh of course you
know uh if you play against maxime you
are playing the sicilian defense so here
we have c5 knight to f3 and d6 now sorry
about that uh we have bishop the b5
check uh this is how anand challenges
the sicilian not with the d4 opening the
position right away bishop to d7 so the
the canal attack with bishop captures
and these seven queen captures and now
pawn to c4
grabbing control over the d5 square and
we as we always say if black still
hasn't played knight to f6 you always
have time to
get to this c4 moving so knight to f6 we
have knight to the c3 now
you can see that this position is much
much better than the pawn being on c2
this way already you have played your
pawn and uh the knight can for example
get the d5 at some point if needed so
knight to c6 and now striking in the
center with the d4 we have captures
captures and pawn to g6 maximum saving
cattle the dark square bishop and the
castle king side and we have f3 bishop
to g7 and the bishop to e3 both players
castle castles castles and now a6 and
interestingly this position has reached
has been reached many many times there
are many popular options here for
example ponte e for his very popular
rook the c1 very popular queen
d2 very popular uh but anand prepared
well for this game uh he knows that
maksim already had this position last
year in the ftx crypto cup he had it
against fabiano caruana caruana played
queen to d3 and he won that game against
maxime so obviously maxime analyzed this
position thoroughly uh because you do
when you are playing at the dare level
you analyze both the games you lose the
games you draw into the games you win
it's like kasparov said the the most
important games to analyze are the ones
that you you win uh because that's where
your opponents will will look for
uh you know the most weaknesses but here
anand completely disregards all of that
and he he prepares a move that has never
been played before he plays knight to b3
so now already as of move 12 we have a
completely new game and what does this
knight to b3 move uh do well it removes
all the tension from the d4 square and
now anand wants to move the queen to e2
which would be impossible
you know with all this pressure and he
wants to bring the rooks this rook to d1
and this rook to c1 so it uh it seems
like a very nice developing idea so here
e6 maxine also continues his development
queen to e2 and now queen to e7 of
course maxime knows that the rook is
coming to d1 so rook after d1 rook after
d8 and rook 8 c1 anand finishes uh his
development we have rook 8 the c8 maxim
also finishes the development and only
now anand brings the knight back to d4
so uh here we have knight to d7 and this
is already a very interesting move in
the position because this is the moment
where anand is asking maxime are you
ready to execute the d5 because if you
uh if there's any player that is always
ready to execute the d5 central
breakthrough
uh it is a maximum vascular graph but
here uh he doesn't do it and it's a very
interesting line uh for example d5 we
have to go for knight captures and c6 to
avoid opening up the center completely
because then black just equalizes knight
captures and c6b captures and now e5 we
challenge the knight knight e7 and now
pawn to f4 and you get this position
which is incredibly flexible nothing is
fixed and you can challenge the center
in a variety of ways you can play f6 to
change e5 you can play g5 to challenge
f4 so many many uh good good options
here even queen to be for putting
pressure on both c4 and some pressure on
b2 so that you can play this many
different ways but maximum goes for
knight to d7 but maxim always plays the
the most interesting idea so this should
not
be all that uh mysterious to us uh and
anand plays b3 and now you have this
classic marotzi bind set up ones on a a
to b three and c four and pawns on g2 f3
and e4 and it's very hard for black to
make any progress here white has an
immense grip on the d5 square you can
see that the pawns controller the knight
controls it the real controls it and
it's just a very hard for black to make
uh
any sort of uh a breakthrough here uh
however maxime finds one it's not the
most safest one uh but he does it anyway
and he plays b5 and this is a classical
mvl move that just you know completely
lights the game
on fire
so what can you do it seems like the
pawn can just be captured because you
are attacking that b5 square four times
but not really now anand goes for it c
captures on b5 but now we play knight
captures on d4 bishop captures bishop
captures rook captures and now there is
no rook on d1 to defend the rook on c1
so we play a captures on b5
and now the knight cannot capture as the
rook on c1 is undefended so the real
challenge to anand is do you capture the
opponent b5
but
this would give maxim too much contra
play ananda agrees uh as for example if
queen captures on b5 it looks amazing
you have two connected past pawns on the
queen side uh you give a really a lot of
counter play to maxine rook c5 attacks
the queen now you have to be careful
next move queen g5 is coming that will
put pressure on the rook here so it's
best to bring the queen all the way back
and now we're just going to play rook d
to c8 and now you have you're not a pawn
with black but you have complete control
over the e5 or over the c file and you
say okay white doesn't really have all
the time in the world to start pushing
those pawns on the queen side now let's
say queen e1 we're going to put the
knight on e5 and now it's just a it's
just a very flexible a and a very nice
position for black and there are many
tricks in the position for example if f4
you want to chase away the knight
there's even queen a7 just uh the king
is still on g1 the rook is on d4 it's
very very
uh
awkward playing this with white so you
have to play king to h1 and now we just
play knight g4 and excellent square for
the knight and if h3 we just bring the
knight back and already there are so
many holes here uh the the white king's
position has been extremely weakened and
after let's say rook captures on d6
we're gonna play queen to c7 and now we
we own the c file for the rest of the
game and uh we have immense pressure
here on the knight if the rook moves uh
we pick up the f4 pawn so even though
white is black is down two pawns for the
moment uh maxim would have insane
counter play here so anand says i'm not
interested in this that's uh you know
those are your kind of positions i'm
just going to play queen to d2 and i'm
going to go after the real weakness in
the game and that is the d6 pawn and
this move is much much stronger than
just grabbing on b5 so here rook to b8
defending the pawn
uh you don't really have a
good way of of dealing with this if you
just defend the pawn we're gonna capture
on b5 uh so
best just to play b5 b4 like like maxime
did but not right away uh first he
defended rook to b8 uh now comes rook
captures on d6 and now pawn to b4 and
again maxime will get counter play for
his sacrifice material knight the e2 now
comes knight the e5 and uh okay how do
you how do you play this now uh we have
rook to d1 just threatening to play rook
captures here and of course any trades
are favorable for anand as he is up
material now so knight to c6 defending
the the rook here and now you can't
really just go trading because then rook
captures and you might have problems
here so here anand finds a brilliancy of
a move and that is pawn to e5 it seems
like it's impossible because the knight
controls that square but the knight
cannot keep an eye on the e5 and the d8
square at the same time so this is just
a beautiful beautiful move and now if
rook captures we're gonna capture with
the pawn here and then have a beautiful
pass pawn on d6 already so queen to a7
check king to h1 and now queen to f2
maxime again always finds counter play
for his sacrifice material
because okay anand has the two pawns
against one on the queen side but uh
this pawn is uh paralyzing the entire
the entire structure this is a backwards
pawn you can't just play a4 uh so it's
not easy for anand to uh you know make
uh make sense of of his extra pawn but
there is one move that allows him to win
this position so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find it the only
move that wins for anand while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
well a beautiful positional move and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is rook the c1 that's the good
stuff so to find this move and i
congratulate you all uh who who were
able to do this uh to find this move you
first have to check what happens if we
just take here well rook captures here
and now our queen is hanging uh so we
have to move the queen and once we move
the queen we first trade rook captures
queen captures and now we just move our
king uh it's going to be incredibly safe
here we don't even want to capture the
e5 pawn the e5 pawn will save us from
all the checks and there is no uh
pressure that the white queen can just
uh mount
alone and you know
the the white king is extremely weak
here on h1 let's say we play knight g1
because we can't move the queen while
our knight is hanging we're gonna start
bringing the knight into the game and
maxim's position would be just much much
better so if you see that this is
impossible you realize that your only
problem is having the rook on d1 so rook
the c1 solves all your problems and
that's how you reach to this conclusion
uh now uh maxim's knight is hanging so
that's that's a big problem and you
can't move it because then just rook
capture 78 wins the game so the only
move here is to capture the rook rook
captures but now anand gets his past
pawn e captures on d6 uh knight to e5
and now we have h3 ananda creates some
breeding room for his king but not only
that he's preparing f4 and he does not
want to give up the g4 square to the
knight if the knight comes to g4 you're
gonna have problems here so rook to b5
and now pawn to f4 moving the knight and
if the knight doesn't go to d7 then we
just start pushing our pass pawn and win
the game so knight to d7 by mvl and now
queen d4 now offering a rook trade a
queen trade and there is no good way to
avoid this it seems like you can for
example capture a free knight here but
rook c8 check and now there's a problem
the queen covers g7 and you have to play
something knight to f8 now you play rook
characters and f8 king captures and
queen the h8 a beautiful checkmate this
is what anand found uh and uh of course
the tactics uh work in his favor so
queen to d for just a beautiful move
offering a free night seemingly uh but
it's actually checkmate if maxine goes
for it so there's really nothing better
uh queen captures was played but now
knight captures attacking the rook and
there is now no wait uh uh
well to do any any sort of resistance
here rook the d5 goes after the pawn
here and the knight but
anand says i'm just going to transfer
one of my advantages to the other uh and
well that's also perfectly fine knight
to c6 now goes after the b4 pawn uh so
rook captures knight captures on b for
now the pawn comes alive and now anand
has two connected pass pawns on the
queen side e5 we have captures on a5
knight captures on e5 and rook to c5 now
attacking the knight rook d1 check king
h2 and now pawn to f6 defending the
knight so anand is up only one pawn uh
but it's too connected past pawns on the
queen side and that's a a
big problem for maxine ponte a4 we have
rook to b1 attacking on b3 just rook c3
anon defends the pawn rook to a1 and now
on move 40 uh anna played rook to c7 and
he was in this position on mu 40 that
maxim vashila grav resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
you might think okay it's too early to
resign it's only one pawn uh the problem
is uh uh okay one pawn sometimes isn't
all that much if you for example have an
active king but here with rook to c7
anand completely uh blocks uh the the
king from entering the game and there's
just no way to find a good move for
black if the king was on c3 instead of
on g8 of course okay not c3 the king
would be in check there but let's say on
d2 then it would be easier to play this
you would have a lot more a lot more
counter play however on g8 there really
is no counter play and to give you an
example uh let's say we go knight f7 we
want to somehow bring the king into the
game we have to block the the the
seventh rank somehow uh we're just going
to play knight d5 go after the pawn
after f5 we play rook a7 and now we just
start advancing our pawns uh let's say
king g7 b4 uh we're gonna bring the king
into the game g5 let's say b5 and now
king to g6 we've managed to bring the
king all the way to the sixth rank but
now b6 white spawns are just too fast
and there's no no dealing with this uh
rook to b1 b7 and now let's say knight
to d8 going after the pawn and it seems
like uh now you've blundered the pawn
but i've prepared a very very cool trick
for you and just uh show you how to how
to win this knight to b6
and that's it next move we promote our
pawn to to a queen of course the knight
cannot capture because the rook defends
and of course if you capture the rook uh
then you say haha i've tricked you i i
got
you got your king to the sixth rank
thinking you've actually made some
progress but this allows me this
beautiful trick with rook to a6 and now
you don't have a move if you capture the
rook we bring a queen into the game and
if you don't there's really nothing for
you to play you can't play rook captures
because the rook is pinned and if knight
captures then we capture the rook with
check once the king moves we capture the
knight and that's it now we promote this
pawn and win the game easily so that's a
little bit of extra fun for those of you
who watched until the end
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it very nice victory for anand
in a classical time control so uh
brilliant brilliant stuff the other game
that finished in classical for those of
you who are interested is wesley silver
system or a job of
if i manage the time i will show that
one as well and there were some
interesting games in armageddon as well
but we are mostly going to cover
classical ones if if like the armageddon
one is incredibly interesting we're
going to cover that one as well uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it round one of the norway chess
has has officially begun uh i would like
to thank nagarjuna ponogoti congrats
harry three grads andre theron alexander
john juar and valentin moreira for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
norway chess tournament until it
finishes so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day